speaking of youtube um
british speaking of youtube youtube i've
been watching a few more youtube shorts
recently even though like like i know
like every time i go on like a youtube
shorts binge
it's like it's like bad for my health
you know like yeah there's it's to me
watching youtube shorts or watching tick
tocks is the equivalent
of
eating mcdonald's or eating fast food
right like i know i shouldn't do it but
sometimes sometimes just lying in bed
and you just scroll through and you're
like you just want that quick meal
and you're like [ __ ] 30 minutes have
passed and i've like consumed nothing uh
so like i've fallen down to like i felt
i fell down into this hole of like you
know life advice youtube or like life
hacks
and it's just like
like
remember before where we went through
that life hack phase of like buzzfeed
videos where like the hack isn't
actually a hack so i thought that died
out but apparently that just went to
[ __ ] tick tock yeah right because
like i i remember i saw i saw like a few
like career hacks of things you can do
in like to help you increase your
chances of getting a job interview right
and there was this i think i saw that
there's this tick tock of like that this
is how this hour goes the job interview
offers you a glass of water
the same thing yesterday
the black guy right yeah
yeah so the job interviewer offers you a
glass of water and then you take the
water and that's the hack because the
hack is if you take the glass of water
when it's offered to you they ask you a
difficult question and you just go
well you see the thing is and then and
the hack was because you have a glass of
water it gives you more time to think
about the answer and that was the hack
and i was just like losing my mind i
thought you could call this career
advice or a [ __ ] 1000 likes and i'm
like
this feels like
like the only time i ever see people
take a sip of water right for answering
the question is it like the criminal
trial
like when mark zuckerberg was being
uh questioned by the senate yeah every
single question it would be asked to go
yeah he was using a life hack dude he
was thinking about those answers i'm
saying you don't look like a criminal
when i ask you a question you don't be
good i'm just i'm just like i i i feel
like a more like logical thing would be
like uh can i just take a bit of time to
think about this answer yeah no no no
because you've got to seem confident
yeah i'd be like that is a fantastic
question yeah think of the way to
appropriately answer that no you you
what if you combine it right yeah yeah
yeah you gotta combine it with the water
that's a fantastic
what if what if the water doesn't give
you enough time
are you just like downing an entire
[ __ ] jugger
you're sitting there for like 10 minutes
just going they're like gone
like what's your fault
your favorite food is oh [ __ ]
well what if or what if you know you're
just like
you get off of the water right and
you're just like really thirsty and then
you get to that really difficult
question you're just like
[ __ ]
like what do i do now
never told me sir you've gone through
three liters of water during this
interview are you are you feeling okay i
want to say like 99 of life hacks or
some [ __ ] i just immediately forget and
never remember and we'll never ever
practically use yeah yeah yeah i've
learned so many of them especially when
it comes to like [ __ ] survival like
these these kinds of like hacks or like
advice you see on tick tocks like i
don't know if we've ever talked about
this on podcast i think we've only
talked about it in private but like the
[ __ ] shaq financial advice which is
an entire genre
which is which is an entire i think an
entire genre of video on tick tock and
youtube shorts now where it's just like
shaq motivational like life advice and
half of it is just like taking your
paycheck and apparently just ripping it
in half shaq what's the difference
between being rich and being wealthy
it's like when you're rich you do this
but the wealth you do this
one million likes
thank you shaq i am no longer poor now
shaq is a very nice guy
the financial advice the problem is with
a lot of these financial advices on like
tick tock and youtube and again i think
shaq is somewhat guilty of this it
assumes
you're even making enough money to save
like most people don't aren't able to
save money because like we're [ __ ]
right now yeah you most people spend all
their paycheck that's that's how it is
how do you then go to them and be like
you're just not saving enough you're
just not saving enough that rent maybe
you can get rid of it yeah yeah who's
who's living on minimum wage and being
like oh i didn't i shouldn't
are there people who spend it
responsibly hell yeah there are yeah is
that the reason why everyone isn't rich
no
and no
it was just so weird falling into this
hole of just like you know you see these
tik tok with like made up scenarios
where the the perfect life hack for that
scenario will pop up it's always the
same it's one guy is in this part of the
frame and he's like so you want this and
then another guy
probably with glasses yeah yeah no no no
that's not how you do it it's literally
always like that and with the worst
acting and the worst script and then
it's like 20 million views and i'm like
i'm quitting much yeah i'm terrible at
my job it's just like an entire [ __ ]
genre of that just takes place in the
dharma universe yeah you know it's just
like the extended darman universe where
you know everything just works out
because of these because i drank water
in my [ __ ] job interview like
the dcu
man cinematic universe
the one that also just like that i've
been getting a lot recently off youtube
shorts is the ones where like
the ones where they take like you know
those like five minute crafts like
[ __ ] like life hacks and then
there's always some like dude who's like
i'm gonna find out if this is actually
legitimate or not and then they do it
and then they tried themselves and like
okay it was legitimate like for more if
that's the thing that's a thing okay
i've seen so many of those like so many
times where it's like oh if you you know
you get a black marker and you draw it
on your hand and then you take a picture
of it on flash then it apparently zaps
you some [ __ ] like that and and it's
always some guy being like
no it's not factor cap all right let's
try it let's try to figure it out
let's try and figure it out my new
favorite shorts or tic toc uh category
is
the tick tocks that need way more
explanation as to what's going on but
they the person doing the video does not
offer any explanation as to why they're
doing the thing they're doing
like what there was one time i watched
this tick tock and it was a guy he was
like so here's how i made a case to
carry my ipad farm and then he makes the
case and i i
me and all the other comments were like
why do you have an ipad phone like i
think i've seen that one with the long
case yeah yeah yeah like and like he
made this video just explaining how he
made a case for his ipad farm and i was
like the whole time like
why did you have an ipad phone no no he
makes this ipad farm
to test out if he could make enough
passive income that's it yeah
to justify making an ipad farm and like
me like there are so many layers to this
tick tock that i just want answers to
i'm like question how are you making
this money first of all yeah like what
passive income revenue are you doing
what is this app you're using yeah like
i know some people run like spotify
farms yeah like i have like tons and
tons of phones and you play the same
song like on luke oh wow and then like
get revenue from it oh [ __ ] um but
obviously like you've used a lot of
electricity so yeah kind of
some things like that but yeah i mean
it's again there's so many of these
where they're like we're going to do
this thing or they're like or you felt
like you just came into like the 90th
episode of the show and you're like what
what is happening and the people making
the videos don't think that like anyone
might need context or something yeah
yeah just one line because like like i
know exactly what you mean now because
they'll always start off the video with
just like last time i made like a dildo
that could fly or something like that
and you guys have been asking me to make
this so i'm going to make it i'm just
like what what what
so many comments saying that you should
make it harder
i'm like what have i missed in the
[ __ ] lore of this you know like how
how far back do i go and the thing is
like it's impossible to like try to like
triangulate this
when you click on their channel or
something right because it's just like
it's not always in chronological order
either i don't know yeah youtube shorts
is like
there's so many different like holes you
can slip down into youtube shorts and
[ __ ] tick tock and it's like insane
as well because like
especially with the youtube shorts
because i don't really use tick tock but
like with youtube shorts it knows
exactly what to recommend you next
because it's like oh you spent one extra
second on this one [ __ ] shaq
motivational tick tock that must mean
you want 20 more yeah that's why like
sometimes i'm like if i watch a video
that [ __ ] for too long i'm like
[ __ ] now the algorithm thing now the
algorithm thinks i like this video and
like the next 10 videos will be
something to do with that i'm like i
wish there was some way to just tell
youtube i didn't like the video that
they sent me but unfortunately they
removed the dislike yeah i know
there's a lot of tick tocks or youtube
shorts that i watch and i'm like i hated
this video i want to let them know i
hated it without being an [ __ ]
um
but i can't now so i just have to and
i've already given them my watch time so
i've for all youtube knows that was the
best experience of my life the one that
uh made me fall down the rabbit hole for
youtube shorts for me is uh i saw this
one youtube short of uh
the the founder of 2chan uh because he
has like a live streaming thing yeah and
he like uh he's called hiroyuki but like
he he's very uh you know because he's
the creator of 2chan yeah he's a bit
based in his opinions okay um gamer like
very controversial right like he's based
in the in a negative yeah based in a
negative term and uh i just watched one
because i couldn't [ __ ] believe the
answer and now
my youtube shorts are just this japanese
dude saying a lot of racist and
controversial [ __ ] and i was like i
don't i didn't i didn't watch this
because i liked it i watched it because
i was trying to process what the [ __ ]
this guy was talking about that's been a
lot of criticism of youtube facebook and
all these platforms they push you to the
more fringes of the content and um yeah
i mean that's one of the parts that's
not so good yeah i think one of the
weirdest ones i've uh the one of the
weirdest genres i've seen that's popped
up recently is we've gotten to the point
where youtube shorts are now
commentating on youtubers oh yeah where
you'll be like lundwig just did this
last week
you won't believe what he did and i'm
just like
this is why saikuno doesn't take
sponsorship
i was like
all right cool i guess like it's like mr
beast just sent chocolate bars to every
influencer you know
you know it's it's like news flash
i don't know it's just it's just so
weird
it's just so weird seeing all these like
new genres and new types of content pop
up um on on i guess like a new for a new
type of platform and everything like
that yeah um but like i don't understand
it at all do you think youtube sure is
gonna stick around do you think it's
going to get to a point where
i mean like [ __ ] around so yeah
it's you know it's what it is but at the
end of the day the long form content is
still very valuable and that's what
makes the money of course yeah until
tick tock find a way to uh properly
monetize that platform without uh paying
their creators way less than uh what
they deserve then uh yeah i think long
long form content
will be king for now that's us that's
that's actually that's what
that's
we have zero bias whatsoever
absolutely zero buyers ridiculously long
videos we only upload six hours of
content a week
but hey that's just a theory a trash
theory